heute einen wunderschönen guten morgen
alter die sonne strahlt heute steht das
geil ist an und damit etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja mittlerweile schon 10 uhr ich muss
jetzt ganz dringend zurück weil wir
fahren heute nach münchen ihr wisst ja
die leute ich bin riesen wären wären ich
hab selber bmw und ja deswegen passt das
umso besser ich wollte mich von bmw
eingeladen auf die diesjährige iaa
2021 in münchen ich war jetzt los und
wir werden morgen einen richtig geilen
tage nehmen ich nehme ich mit und stelle
ich alle neuen sachen alle neuen
technologien die neuen autos von bmw und
so weiter vor also bleibt auf jeden fall
dran wenn ihr euch für autos
interessiert so sehr wie ich und ich
würde sagen let's go und meine freundin
marie kommt auch mit was sagst du dazu
aber die kommt morgen nicht mehr auch
die automesse so leute wir sind jetzt in
meinem bmw gerade noch und fahren jetzt
mal bahnhof war von da aus geht es
direkt bezogen nach münchen und mich mit
sagen wir sehen uns bist im zug wieder
nicht drückt jetzt aus kaarst damit bei
denen ich verpassen ist er nämlich recht
so leute auto geparkt ich hoffe dass
kann da gut stehen bleiben und steht
darüber morgen immer noch und jetzt
geht's los
leute was geht wir sind jetzt schon seit
vier stunden im zug ca aber meine
verspätung und 50 minuten weil haltet
euch fest der lokführer stand im stau
warten wir es einfach mal mit eher
losfahren hemlock führer auf jeden fall
könnt ihr hier jetzt noch die letzten
häuser von stuttgart sehen und ich
möchte mich dann auf jeden fall wenn ich
in mich
[Musik]
endlich geschafft
es hat aber auch gedauert halb acht
haben wir jetzt am ball dabei
erstmal jetzt auch unterwegs war ja klar
ich habe dann auch noch nicht gesehen
vorher darf ich freunde sitzen
[Musik]
da mal rein gehst du nach hinten marie
ist das okay
nicht schlecht nach bestimmt spaß damit
definitiv
nach dem alten system drinnen jetzt
passend zu ihr
habe ich jetzt hier aus versehen auf
stadt gemacht
leute wir haben es geschafft endlich im
hotel das noch echte lange reise nun ist
hieraus im bett werden sehr hoch und
hier immer noch eine schöne dusche immer
wunderbar alles was man braucht nicht
gehen auf jeden fall jetzt ein
gemütliches braucht essen da was ich
denke mal danach gehe ich aber auch
direkt schlafen denn das reicht
anscheinend heute und wir sehen uns dann
morgen früh wieder leute rein bis morgen
leute was geht monaten morgen es ist
endlich soweit donnerstag auch ein
aufzug ich habe gut geschlafen ich will
jetzt abgeholt dann geht es auf die iaa
ich habe bock und der wirklich
anzupacken wenn ich jetzt ganz ganz viel
spaß
da ist es doch was haben wir denn heute
wieder wunderbar
[Musik]
so leute ich bin jetzt hier im ersten
spot angekommen das ist ein bisschen
dunkel
park und zwar ist das hier kannst du
schon sehen dass david automatisch world
parking ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt
was jetzt passiert das ist auf jeden
fall das parken dazu kommt wir parken
die autos automatisch ein es gibt eine
suchoption eine pick up town wo man sein
auch schon einfach abgeben kann und dann
zum beispiel einkaufen kann ins kino
oder wo auch immer und ich dachte dass
jetzt gleich testen zusammen mit dem
peter der fans jetzt noch um zu zeigen
dass man auf leute also leute passt man
auf das ibp automotive world parking
lässt sich eigentlich ganz einfach
erklären die parkhäuser sind komplett
mit kameras ausgestattet die die autos
im parkhaus immer genau beobachten
dadurch weiß das system immer wo sich
welches fahrzeug gerade befindet
passende freie parkplätze werden erkannt
und im jeweiligen autors zugewiesen
dabei setzt die technik im auto die
befehle der infrastruktur in fahrmanöver
um zurück geht es dann genauso alles
stoiber über zb die bmbf der schlüssel
staunen ja so das ist die normale bienek
ja wie kann ich wie kennst und da haben
wir eben jetzt neu automatisch valley
parking jetzt sehen wir dann ja nach wie
vor gefangen also wir fahren jetzt noch
okay job auf und ergaben dass eine zone
genug also keiner weise in einem
richtigen richtigen ernährung wird es
natürlich eine stelle machen direkt vom
eingang in schwerin habe oder hätte
wir sind jetzt an der job auf und hat
sich mal mit staaten weil die apps oder
müssen wir direkt aussteigen wir steigen
jetzt
du sagst du hast du haben willst mich
war schon laden willst ja alles machen
der app store
erst alles mitgenommen das auto ist
gleich wegwerfen was machen wir hier
stark
auf
das ausland
ich hatte durch die halle
münchen
der wagen aus
so verpassen
die automatischen wird derzeit
[Applaus]
envio dann klicken
und jetzt hat man hier man kann gut
sehen das auto erkennt perfekt
hindernisse wird den herren hier oder
auch diesen einkaufswagen angehalten
wollen auch wenn kinder im parkhaus
unterwegs sind super super sicher
so leute ich bin es mittlerweile in der
messehalle und hier sind wir es bei bmw
der standort von leister sich zeigen
euch mal von vorn ich abraten vor
aufnahmen gemacht mir persönlich gefällt
er jetzt auf jeden fall ziemlich gut ich
finde die vier nur noch besser wie
sollen wir es gleich nochmal an das ist
wirklich ein richtig richtig geiles auto
da kannst du wirklich vorstellen das ist
mein nächstes auto fährt wo leute jetzt
erstmal mittagspause ist bmw ich bin
markus a
von hier oben kann ich die autos noch
viel besser zeigen
[Musik]
ich merke schon heute ich hab hier auf
jeden fall ein passant rest wird heute
erwischt
der edeljoker leute endlich mal wieder
in der sonne wir fahren jetzt ins open
space was cool ist mit einem
wasserstoffauto
ich bin also auf jeden fall im auto wir
sitzen hier im x5 heute wird das klingt
erst mal ziemlich futuristisch würde ich
sagen und das besondere ist dieses auto
faehrt mit wasserstoff ich habe gar
nicht damit gerechnet dass ich jemals in
den nächsten jahren in so einem auto
sitzen werde deswegen falls mir jetzt
umso mehr vorne sitzt ja dr grüttner der
uns ein bisschen was dazu erklären kann
ich habe nämlich einige fragen bei mir
näher wird mir jetzt keine tankstelle
einfallen wo ich dann tanken kann in
anführungsstrichen wie ist das geplant
also sie haben gerade schon gesagt du
hast gar schon gesagt dass aktuell 100
tankstellen
in münchen zum beispiel 55 ok und
deswegen in münchen kann man relativ
einfach eine tankstelle anfahren
wasserstoff war der vorgang ist so
einfach wie das heute getränken auch in
den nächsten jahren erwarten wir aber
dass noch viel mehr tankstellen dazu
kommen herein
die nutzfahrzeuge also lkw insbesondere
schwerlaster aber auch busse fernbusse
vor allem mit wasserstoff betrieben
werden müssen weil da die batterie
electric irgendwo an die grenzen stoßen
die frage die mir eigentlich dann so
oder die ich am interessantesten finde
was kostet das in sein auto voll zu
tragenden kosten pro kilometer gerechnet
sind ungefähr so viel wie benzin oder
diesel hocke in deutschland kostet ein
kilogramm wasserstoff 9 euro 50 und
damit komme ich nun die 100 kilometer
weil je nach fahrstil und fahrzeug wenn
du jetzt mit dem auto fährst also ist es
dann auch vom fahrgefühl anders als mit
man weise nicht mit einem x5 oder so es
ist eigentlich das kleine elektrische
fahrgefühl ja das ist dahingleiten gutes
beschleunigungsverhalten wie viel besser
da der hat fast 400 tsc 100
beschleunigen
ja da wird man auf jeden fall schon im
sitzen leute heile angekommen einfach
ein geiles auto so leute wir sind jetzt
hier mittlerweile im open space
angekommen und hinter mir stehen zwei
wundervolle bmw
54 auf jeden fall ein paar kurz
aufnahmen und ansatz für streit
[Musik]
so leute die haben auf jeden fall eine
große ausnahme gemacht dass ich mich
jetzt hier einsetzen darf weil das auto
ist ja noch gar nicht auf dem markt
leute wie geil ich sitze einfach im bmw
i 4 m 50 das ding hat 544 ps geht also
gut nach vorne von 0 auf 100 in 3,9
sekunden es wird glaube ich ungefähr 2,3
tonnen guck mal das geht wie bei meinem
hier so schön mit dem i wurden auch
schön dann haben wir hier so ein
langgezogenes display
und hier kann man einiges machen dann
kann man hier auf jeden fall schonmal
temperatur und so weiter verstellen die
anlage ist auch schon angegangen wenn
man hier ein radiosender wählen sunshine
live wird bei mir immer gehört habt ihr
natürlich auch wenn man da ist er doch
es ist einfach so schade dass ich den
ich fragen kann ich würde ihn jetzt so
gerne fahren aber es geht einfach nicht
der ist wohl noch im kunden internen
test aber ich bin froh dass ich euch
diesen einmal gas geben konnte und
hinten sieht dann so aus habt ihr
sicherlich auch schon gesehen und es hat
mir jetzt auf jeden fall sehr glücklich
gemacht einzusetzen so leid ich mache
mir noch einen kleinen rundgang wir
haben das hier ist der bmw wissens
zirkular natürlich ja das liegt noch in
weiter zukunft wobei wer weiß aber so
sieht das denn aus
alter schon zigmal die felgen also das
auto kommt so natürlich leider noch
nicht aus ich bin mal gespannt ob das
die zukunft ist aber liegt
wahrscheinlich nach wir schauen da auch
gerne mal rein leute was geht ich habe
leider irgendwann aufgehört zu filmen
wir waren dann noch abend zusammen was
essen das ganze team von bmw war von der
agentur und auch andere influenza lade
ich euch hier super gerne macht ein
waren ultraleichte abend und damit haben
wir dann das event auch sozusagen
abgeschlossen erst dann ging es dann für
mich wieder sieben stunden mit dem zug
zurück nach hause und ich habe das
wochenende das war gar kein wochenende
aber es hat sich angefühlt ich hab's
ultra genossen danke auf jeden fall noch
mal ein bmw für die einladung in der
video beschreibung kommen die zu den
autos alle infos auch zum mvp also zu
dem odenwald parken check das gerne ab
falls euch dafür interessiert ich
bedanke mich zu schauen bis übermorgen
wieder gibt's das video leute haut rein